get that dream out of your head and put
it into reality
and do it with squarespace they make it
easier than ever to launch that passion
project
do you want to showcase your work or
sell products of any kind
now is the time with beautiful templates
and the ability to customize just about
anything
you can easily make a beautiful website
by yourself but if you get stuck
it happens they have 24 7 award-winning
customer support that is there to help
you out
so head to squarespace.com grace for a
free trial
and when you're ready to launch use the
offer code grace to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain
hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host
grace helbig very exciting episode with
the one and only margaret cho
comedian activist dog lover
sous-vide expert as i've found out this
episode you'll learn a lot about it
we also get to hear about uh her career
and she gives some really really great
tips on
uh turning your life around if you find
yourself in a hard time or in any sort
of struggle
she is just so charming just so lovely
enjoy this episode of not too deep with
margaret chow
[Music]
margaret thank you for being here this
is very exciting
thank you thank you you look very um
cool and comfortable thank you i have my
um
friend here oh thank you for bringing it
lucia i'm here uh
i was gonna start by saying thank you
for the lucia instagram content
because there's something so calming
about it that it's very very necessary
and
lovely so thank you she's really
incredible
and um she's just amazing especially
during these uncertain times
um you know and she's just been an
amazing
present especially when i wear lipstick
she really loves she wants to get at
this lipstick
how long have you had lucia she's i've
had her for a year and um a year and
eight months
she's about a year and uh
she's about a year and 11 months so yeah
but
she's almost yeah a year and 11 months
something like that
wow but she's great she's so
so sweet uh has she formed an even
more intense bond with you over the last
few months
i think so well we always traveled
together
anyway yeah and uh she's kind of like a
marsupial because she wears
like she wears herself in a little pouch
around my neck so she's always in this
like stomach pouch
and um so lately uh i've been trying to
get her out of the habit of it
um only just because i thought oh well
why don't you just try to sit in my lap
but
she just will get inside my shirt too
so you know if i don't have the pouch
she'll put herself
in my shirt yeah and um so that works
too so but i have to wear like a loose
fitting shirt
she'll like um she got in the habit of
it
uh when i had um
like a night dress on and then she would
get in
on the under the shirt night dress and
she would get on
my back and then so i would put her in
the front
um so i could sort of be like more in in
a way aware of her she's the best oh
it's so so sweet did you how did you
uh how did you guys come together she's
from the
michelson's found animal rescue she was
rescued from
a kill shelter with her entire litter
and she um my friend
works at animal rescue
and um so they alerted me about this
litter that was coming in and um
so her whole uh litter got rescued
and the mom got um rescued like the mom
got adopted first
wow and so she has the same like her mom
and her siblings all look exactly the
same but they're all different colors
oh cute and they're all about the same
size
it's funny because her mom has like but
her mom looks like she's wearing like
husky makeup
yeah like she's dressed up as a husky
for halloween like she's got like the
husky eyebrows
and um you know just like you did husky
drag
yeah and then her um brothers
are like kind of have like sort of
dalmatian brown
coloring and like brown spotted and then
her sister is uh white but with a black
nose and
black eyes and she has like kind of um
brown hazelish green eyes and a
chocolate milk chocolate nose like a
milk chinos uh i think it's like milk
tea and boba coloring she's kind of
cappuccino
she's uh the i mean everything about her
is a very
like calming aura
and she has kind of a rose tea
uh kind of milky undertone so she's kind
i guess she's like a fall autumn
palette yeah and she has like kind of
ballet
pink ears and yeah she's just a very
calming um she's kind of mad at me
lately because i've been brushing her
teeth
which she just hates really okay but
you've taken the step to actually get in
there with a toothbrush
yeah it was hard because she's such a
small mouth so i have to like go through
several toothbrushes to find the right
size and
we do it like the last thing at night
she gets her toothbrush at the very
because she's tired so it's easy for me
to get in there when she's
sort of not expecting it so i get in
there
really really late at night and i brush
her teeth and she's like
so mad and then she wakes up and she's
like ah
like she gets really mad when you do it
but at the very end then i give her
chicken toothpaste because i can't
really brush her teeth when there's
toothpaste
on it yeah i give her the toothpaste at
the end as like a treat so she knows
like to expect
like a treat at the end that it's worth
it
yeah so it's like chicken whipped cream
okay i didn't know that that kind of
stuff existed but that's cool
that's what it's it's got like a chicken
flavor
okay so uh but it's kind of got a
whipped cream kind of like well it's
more like a bear blanc
it's more like okay and it does clean
the teeth
it does clean the teeth and um it has
some sort of
like you know abrasive agents in it but
it has a chicken flavor and it's good
for them
and she likes it that's great i mean
that makes me wonder why we haven't
in the human world like taking risks in
like a savory toothbrush
or toothpaste scenario i know why don't
we have like a butter
a toothpaste or like a sour cream
toothpaste i don't know if they always
say like if you can't brush your teeth
you should eat like a piece of cheddar
cheese
that's probably like the best thing oh
really i've never heard that
um yeah it's supposed to like somehow be
um
a coating for the teeth that's somehow
better than
like a the worst environment for your
teeth is like um
sugar uh yeah that makes sense or i
think an
acid like an orange juice thing is like
the worst thing you can do
right the best thing is like a um some
kind of a
uh like a i guess a cheddar cheese
so they should have like a cheddar
cheese like a bacon cheddar
um i didn't know i would get so much
knowledge about
uh hygiene dental hygiene for dogs
immediately
thank you of course of course um
now margaret you've had this uh bonkers
career and i i think it's so wildly
impressive
um the the trajectory of your career in
terms of like
being someone involved in the
entertainment industry for so
long because it feels like you know the
entertainment industry is very
draining and very exhausting and you
found this way
to like stay very true to yourself and
kind of navigate it which is
i think so so freaking cool um
especially with you know technology and
everything kind of evolving and all of
that
uh you must be exhausted
uh i want to talk to you about a couple
things one the most recent situation of
the masked
singer uh in which you sang as the
poodle
on this program how was that experience
because it seems very wild to have an
entire
studio audience screaming take it off to
you
at the end of singing a song
it was so fun i really had a great time
um doing it it's such a weird
thing to do um a show
where uh you're singing and
so much of um entertainment really is
about
context and who you are in relationship
to an audience and
right how they know you and um so
it's strange to kind of go on to
something where they know you're
supposed to be
famous right and they know that you're
supposed to be
um talented your [ __ ] you should be
right right
and they should know you from something
but they don't exactly know and it's
such a
weird thing um so i guess
that it's kind of like yeah meta show
business and that it's like
how do we know you why do we know you
and what is this supposed to be and
so it's interesting um it's a korean
invention
yeah that's it it's been adopted over
here was that strange to be doing the
american
version of it yes because i'm also very
into korean entertainment i'm like very
crazy about um
korean drama and kpop and so
um you know and i am korean so it's a
very
interesting thing to be i mean we hadn't
we haven't adopted as much korean
variety programming so
it's it's great that that show is such a
big hit here
um so it's a it's an uh it's a great
adaptation
and i think it's also great for us as a
as a country just because all of our
entertainment and
all of our everything about america is
so divisive
yeah you know like everything that we do
is like it's us against them and that
show no matter who you are politically
socially
where you stand uh even on masks yeah
yeah
everybody likes it yeah wow i never put
that together that is very true
it does uh it does uh take that boundary
away
for people uh yeah that's very i love it
so it's funny it must have been nice to
also to be involved with something where
you nest didn't necessarily
have to talk politics that it was
just exactly what it was yeah
which is cool and also you know that
that kind of
thing of like where it's it's a i like
like a big shiny floor they call them
like those shiny floor shows where
it's really it's very old school
entertainment where they don't even
approach
any kind of um thing like where it's
also not very
um much about like where they don't know
when they're going to air it so they
they don't necessarily could be live
or it might be not rooted in the moment
and so they can sort of like hold it for
a long time or they
could just like play it right then or
it's because they have to do so much
um sort of secrecy with that program and
that
they don't want anybody in the audience
to leak out who it is so they right they
do
so much like subterfuge where you're
like being hidden from
the the audience you're being hidden
from the other players you're being
hidden
from the judges you're being hidden from
even like um
when you go with the people that you're
you're usually traveling with whether
it's like your manager your agent or
your
public sister those people are also in
masks
wow which is really funny yeah i guess
that makes sense because if someone
knows who your agent or manager is they
can probably figure out that you're
there
yeah because so many people have their
you know their team is made up of their
family members
and their friends and everybody knows
who's your
crew right right so you're gonna know
like as soon as you see somebody that
you're
uh hanging out with they're gonna know
who you're you're with like so that's
like kind of
part of the um game and then also like
anytime you go to like a rehearsal space
you're there um totally isolated so
they're taking us to different places
that
are like not around the other people
that are on the show
and then if you're in a situation with
the other people that are contestants
the other masked
singers they're not in their costume
so they have like other actors in the
costume so you don't
have a chance to talk to the people
because you know we'll talk to them
right right you know i'm gonna go
who's in there i i'm straight up gonna
go
take it off i was like
but tommy chong walked by me and i
smelled weed and i'm like oh that's
[ __ ] tommy john
because i know him from life yeah so i
was like because i've recorded a song
with him before so i was like
oh that's tommy john because i totally
smelled his
wings you knew exactly what to strangle
him
so i was like oh it's tommy because it's
like you're it's unmistakable his
strength so he's like
oh it's [ __ ] tommy trump because it
was like
that's tommy town and it was so funny
because i knew it
and it was just you could just tell so
that was really
funny it's also funny how heightened all
of your other senses for like deductive
reasoning come into play when you're
trying to figure this thing out
well it's also cool too because it does
combine something that you are really
passionate about which is music
and uh i think that's how did you how
did you get into music was music before
comedy were they kind of at the same
time or was one
leading into the other well my mother is
a singer and my father
um is a piano player and that's how they
met
um my mother sang uh in the church choir
and my father played piano in different
churches all over
korea so they met in the sort of music
like church circuit in in korea and so
um and then when i was really young i
was
in a small band of uh singers
like i was about five and i was singing
in this like
choir of little girl asian singers and
then we were like
singing in these like little like
public television shows in san francisco
and then i got
fired because i kept waiting i couldn't
stop waving at my mom
and i was like scared and i was like my
nervous
chick would be like waving at my mom
from the from like in the audience from
the stage
yeah and i was like like crying and
stuff
and so like i was kicked out because i
was like
so like immature i couldn't separate
myself from like the that sort of thing
of like
just not i wouldn't stop and i couldn't
get into performance mode so i was like
kicked out of the band
and so that sort of was like my entry to
it and then i played piano
um as a really young kid and i started
guitar like very young but i i i
originally started as a piano player and
then
it was like very much i think um always
part of like you know when you're korean
you always are encouraged to play
but it's sort of like they either
push you towards a life as a
sort of classical pianist or
cellist or you know you're you're close
towards a
classical music and you have to be
the best or you're discouraged
yeah you know like you're a little bit
oppressed if you don't show promise as
like
yeah if you're not if you're not a
virtuoso if you're not
like in the top point one for one one
one one one percent whatever
they say don't do it just quit wow
so it's kind of like if you're not going
to be the best you're
you know if you're not first your last
that kind of mentality
which is i think everything you know
yeah
it is really hard yeah that sounds very
difficult and also a
slight training for i guess hollywood in
some
regard absolutely absolutely
for sure it's the same thing yeah well
you've also
so you you're doing your podcast now and
i've been
like doing some internet stalking of you
and it seems like you're
you're really busy in terms of like
maintaining conversations with people
because i know right time
right now it's a little bit difficult
and interesting for comedians to kind of
navigate you know
the world right now and how to figure
out this new
adapt to performing in different regards
like how have you
kind of navigated the last few months in
terms of like
staying in entertainment creating things
getting out there that sort of thing
it's weird it's very much like
trying to stay connected through um yeah
podcasting
um i'm doing some um
work on indie film and doing some
um stuff well there's some like voice
over things
um anything that's kind of not
uh i mean going i've gone into some
bubbles to do some things which are very
intense because you're like
in the bubble like you're you're testing
to go in the bubble and then you're like
going in
it's that's crazy to me and that's
really hard um
but i've done like some animation stuff
like i have a movie coming out um
in really soon called over the moon oh
yeah
yeah yeah which is beautiful um so
that's great you know um but there's
like
some stuff that is just like you know
i i i want to happen but you just have
to wait like comedy
aesthetic comedy is is really hard on
zoom
yeah yeah it's really hard on instagram
live i mean i love
doing it i love doing stand-up comedy
it's very
challenging on these um platforms so
yeah
um i haven't done a drive-in show yet i
would love to
that would be great so we'll see um but
i really miss doing comedy that's really
the hardest thing i mean especially you
know
like everyone says especially right now
i feel like it's
uh both extremely necessary for
comedians to be able to be performing
and also really daunting
there's a lot going on and like how do
you you've always been a very
uh true to yourself outspoken creative
how do you manage wanting to talk about
everything that's happening in the world
versus like wanting to kind of process
everything that's happening in the world
well i've been doing like um right now i
just started to
help um out with the um
biden harris campaign which is really
great
um so i'll be working on that um
for uh the next whatever 40 something
days
until which everybody's like
so worried about which i get but it's
enough time
yeah it's enough time we have enough
time plus we have
the last four years to look back on like
look at how much
he's [ __ ] up yeah i mean it's it's
undeniable and it's uh
it boggles my mind that there are still
humans that refuse to acknowledge
some of it because that to me takes way
more
emotional energy to like deny what's
happening
than to just like admit that your
alliances are very wrong
well the insanity of it and it's like
the um
also the goal yeah yeah to sort of
keep and maintain that position and the
the um ridiculous idea
that that's not going to completely
destroy
our democracy you know that's
that's the problem is that it's not just
going to
mess up the next four years this is
going to mess up
the last 225
for whatever 230 240
i mean you know we're really we're
really in a dangerous position i mean
it's very
terrifying so it's it
is really wild but it's very cool to
see it here that you're lending as much
support as you can to get things going
do you have because i know myself
included a lot of people are just like
what is what can i do like what's
something that i can like focus on
like do you have any tips or advice or
suggestions for people in those
terms because i think it's really easy
to get very overwhelmed by like the
grand
the grand scale of everything rather
than like focusing on the smaller more
accomplishable tasks i think it is just
supporting
um the people that we want to support
and supporting the messages of people
that we want to support
and just getting behind it and getting
excited about
these small victories you know to me
like these small victories are
are important like i i really get around
things like um promoting the idea of
um let's end systemic racism let's look
towards
change and let's look towards um this
idea of prison reform like i was excited
that um gavin newsom signed this bill
that's going to allow
people in who are incarcerated who are
fighting
the california wildfires to become
firefighters when they get out of prison
which i think is really important
so i think that's really great so i've
been a big fan of gavin newsom since he
was
mayor of san francisco and he's a friend
of mine and so
you know i'm i'm really thrilled that
he's changing things around for people
in california and
you know wildfires here are really a
problem because
of climate change yeah and you know the
the bobcat wildfire is really it's right
by our house actually lucia was coughing
the other day when the wildfire started
because
it's the smoke is in our air you know
and they're in her little
little tiny little milky tea lungs
so it's really sad yeah i mean yeah when
you see it
affecting like actually affecting i i
mean i've seen the photos from up in san
francisco and
they look out of a movie like they don't
look
real and it's hard to process because
your brain tries to create like a
distance of like that's not possible
it's not happening but it really is
oh well okay we're going to take a quick
break when we get back i have a bunch
more questions for you so we'll be right
back with more not too deep
[Music]
it is the time for you to turn your
dream into a reality and guess who's
here to help you do
it squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch that passion project that
you got ratnle around in your brain cage
if you're looking to start a new
business if you want to showcase some
work or publish content sell products or
more
squarespace is the tool for you they
have beautiful templates created by
world
class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything in a few
clicks so you can easily
make a beautiful website all on your own
they also have powerful ecommerce
functionality that lets you sell
anything online
and analytics that help you grow your
site in real time
and everything is optimized for mobile
right out of the box there's nothing to
patch
or upgrade ever buying domains is simple
and you can get the help you need
with their 24 7 award-winning customer
support
squarespace empowers millions of people
designers lawyers
artists gamers restaurants gyms to turn
great ideas into something real
so head to squarespace.com grace for a
free trial
and when you're ready to launch use the
offer code grace to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain that's squarespace.com
grace offer code grace
i kind of joke with my boyfriend now but
it is also something serious of like
should we have more of a plan should we
have more of like
things like cans of food and water
and uh more of an actual sort of like
backup situation for ourselves do you
have anything like that
um no but like when i uh with um
my the guy that i go out with we we're
going to like some of the
um protests you know yeah and we're like
is there gonna be tear gas should we
bring milk
yeah and we only have like we're
non-dairy so we should we have almond
milk
does that work for tear gas i don't know
yeah they're like this is the most
insane question i'm
legitimately asking myself right now i
know it's like
what do vegans do for tear gas
it's like really hard to figure that out
it's like
you know true it's very true very real
yeah um well in
you you are vegan uh not really but
we're not we're just not
we're just not we're trying not to do
too much dairy
yeah no that makes sense uh
in the in the last you know few months
have you noticed any of
uh or have you developed any really
healthy habits
or any really awful habits um
neither really healthy or awful although
now i'm i'm cooking
on the high end and low end of the
temperature
scale so i either do i cook at
either 150 degrees
or at 500 degrees
whoa what do i do i see these first
oh and then i uh blaze at so i
i do the sous vide depends on what it is
so i'll sous vide for
uh sometimes 24 to 48 hours and then
i'll blast it either on the um
weber outside or the uh broiler inside
whoa i don't have a full i don't have a
flamethrower or a
torch wait so what what kind of cooking
is this
it's souvenirs um it's under uh it's a
water bath
right it's like vacuum sealed vacuum
seal it and then you put it into
a water bath for um you know depends on
what it is
vegetables you would do like 160 to 184
degrees depending on
how hard it is how much water there is
in it okay and then um
meats you would do um if
there's like a bone in it um or how much
conductivity or how much fat or
connective tissue is in it it depends on
what it is
okay um so uh in general
i think um yeah meats i would do because
if it's like got a lot of connective
tissue i would break it down for like 24
hours or 48 if it's like really hard
if it's like um an oxtail or something i
would do like 48 hours
whoa how long have you been cooking this
way
um for about for since march wow cool
so yeah it's been good it's been really
it's been really interesting because i
can sort of
really see how it's been very
uh creative and it's been a way to kind
of
look to food as like at least becoming a
little bit more interesting
yeah than just like broiling a chicken
breast
yeah yeah yeah what was the what was the
impetus that got you into this
i've always enjoyed cooking but i've
never had time
so this is like a way to utilize the
time and like korean cooking is all
about fermentation
okay and you know spending like
several uh days on a dish where you
would like take it and put it outside in
these clay pots and it's about the
seasons and about drying and
fermenting um vegetables and
and and beans and using these flavors
and using the seasons to cultivate these
flavors and
you know certain seasons like you would
uh bring forth flavors like certain
seasons bring forth
fish and fruit and vegetables and you
know those kinds of things
are really inherent to the korean
palette and so
i thought well let's try i don't do that
that much but
i definitely was like into like oh let's
try to see if we can do it with
the technology we have around sous vide
and i have a chef's kitchen
so i'm gonna actually like i just had it
remodeled like
two years ago but i've never used it i
used to use like my stove as a clock
so don't actually like use it now it's
nice
it turns out it has a couple other
functions that you can use it for
it's really beautiful and i have a steam
i have a steam oven too
um so that's been helpful for like um
you know uh seafood and
lobster and crabs and things like that
you know so that's beautiful
as well yeah no that's really cool to
actually like explore
the like a different style of cooking
and actually kind of like appreciate the
process
of it yeah i mean but stupid is really
marvelous because i always like
uh burn things that like especially like
steak like really
nice beautiful like a wagyu steak like i
always [ __ ] it up
yeah same beautiful like a dry aged
steak like a
a really like nice steak i all i want to
make like
medium rare and i always [ __ ] it up like
it's always like
burnt or like bloody raw like wrong
and so what i do is i cook it for two
hours
and in in the sous vide and like cook it
all the way through but it's like still
red in the center
and then i just blaze the outside for
like a minute
and so it's like got a hard crust and
it's cooked all the way through but it's
still got a
cool red center but it's cooked so it's
like
you know you just make it perfectly
yeah to your liking and then blaze the
outside
so i gotta try you in restaurants yeah
yeah
restaurants i've seen it done on top
chef uh but it just looks like this
insane magic trick that i couldn't
possibly do on my own
so i'm happy and inspired to hear that
your take you're doing and it sounds
like it's working really well
it's so smart i mean thomas keller said
that i mean thomas keller so smart and
he said in his book like if you get a
suv then you really start working with
it
i think it's it's it's really smart he
said that
you um would use it more than your
microwave and it's true
wow really i actually do i do use the
sous vide every day
and i find that it's much easier because
like i'll like
vacuum seal something and i'll i'll just
throw it in the sous vide in the morning
and then i'll have something that night
or you know i'll just
and i'll use like the plastic bags i'll
just rinse out and i'll use them again
oh okay unless it's chicken or something
then i won't use them again but it's
like you know
very much like i i mean i i'm really
conscious about
the use of like that's the one thing
that bothers me is the use of plastic
but i
i will like use it again so it's kind of
um
it's been efficient that's really cool
and also like everyone went through
their big
bread making face of quarantine i feel
like bring on the sous-vide
phase of quarantine right now it's good
it works um have you had a
frequent house guest in uh the
quarantine situation
um i have i've been seeing a
guy who my oat milk friend
okay um he might
protest friend okay um other than that
um keep keeping it low-key no yeah
i have oh so i the one thing that i
truly truly admire about you so much is
how open you've been about your whole
life story and how transparent
you've been and it just it seems very
very cool to be able to present
sort of uh with humility your life and
let people relate to it in whatever way
they can or or will uh do you
feel pressure to be so transparent
online or to be
voicing your opinions because i'm sure
you know like every person
especially a comedian especially female
that tries to say something about
anything going on in the world
people want to shoot you down and tell
you to shut up and etc like
how do you balance that
oh well i don't care i mean i don't
really care like to me it's also like
i'm also very much like i'm always
trying to make jokes
so it's like whatever i can mine as a
subject
for jokes i'm much more desperate to do
that
than i am to worry about opinions about
what people might think so
i'm just so like hungry to like
have subjects to talk about like because
you're just
constantly burning through like material
in every context like i always need to
like have jokes to write about and like
something to write about like something
so it's way more essential for me to
like
take that sort of idea of privacy and
throw that out the window like
it's like also who cares like doesn't
matter very true it really doesn't
so i need i need to talk about whatever
i can talk about in order to have
something to talk about
totally like what's your do you have a
process for writing jokes are you just
sort of kind of open
and conversational and like sort of
filtering through things and making note
of things that like sound more
interesting to kind of
experiment with yeah i mean i also like
try to think about like what do i like
to hear about
and like what do i like to say to people
and what do i think is funny
and like what do i like to tell people
about myself and then just sort of
extend that
into what is interesting to like tell
an audience you know isn't the audience
is really just an extension of
friendships and like um so you know it's
just an audience it's just people so
it's
it's more just um presenting yourself as
a friend
to um a group of people as opposed to
just one
other person so it's really just that
you know um that that's that's the only
process that i have and it's just trying
to remember and trying to record that
and
and so it's it's like a process of doing
that over and over
but that's why being on stage is so
important because it's a it's a constant
thing and then when you're not doing
that it's really hard to
figure out even who you are as a person
because yeah
like so much of my um life has been
about processing that as a performer
and so um for doing that for like 35
years and so now like not having that is
very strange
fair yeah i bet um which is probably why
you know podcasting and that sort of
thing is nice to feel some sort of sense
of like talking things through
in a way do you do you have anyone
well first of all what's like your
relationship with social media do you
hate it
do you tolerate it do you love it
i like it i mean i think it's fun i
think it's definitely interesting
it's something that is there and it's
something that is funny and i i
definitely
i [ __ ] with it like i engage with it and
i like it
um it's new still in my mind even though
it's been around for a long time
yeah it's still like in my mind it's
still like a new thing which is
it's not but it's like anything in the
last 20 years in my mind is still like
new which is such a dumb um
kind of old-person thought but it is
definitely
like uh newfangled but i i know that um
it's all that sort of we have right now
which is good i mean at least we have
that
at least that's in existence so i'm i'm
grateful for it for sure
is there anyone that you follow that you
are obsessed with
any recommendations that people should
be checking in on
i like um i always love billy eichner
and i always like
um uh i was so excited about liam
sullivan
who is an old friend of mine who yeah
oh and you're in the video for it yeah
i loved um shoes yeah yeah i love
i i always loved his older videos we did
a show together in new york many many
years ago and
so he was in it with shoes with kelly
and and so it was great to see
and do masks with him and then and then
um
so i love that i love um
i love cardi b and megan the stallion
and i love
all of those like the tick tock [ __ ] um
challenge video i love like tick tock
like dance challenge and then i'm like
should i do that and i'm like i don't
think my knees can handle it like i
don't want to go
[Laughter]
[Applause]
like i can't i just cannot go for
orthopedic surgery right now like i
don't want
the most embarrassing adult injury is
one you got from trying to do a tick
tock dance
i know no way no no way um
so i can't i can't do it but i i
yeah i just and that i just like to
watch like so many
i watch way too many like a dog videos
like i watch
a lot of like dog and like um
just stupid dog memes yeah it's really
wonderful
i i feel you those are the ones that i
think uh
ground me a little bit uh okay
we're gonna take one last break when we
get back i have a bunch of questions uh
from instagram for you
so speaking of social media we'll be
right back with more not too deep
[Music]
hello listeners grace helbig here
wanting to say two things
a big thank you for listening to the
podcast
uh if you're a regular listener if this
is your first time listening welcome and
thank you
and uh second thing if you are enjoying
yourself here
in this not too deep world we've built
and you'd like to leave us a review that
would be
so wonderful if you can go to the itunes
store the app store and leave us a
lovely little
review comment how are you feeling good
bad otherwise
maybe just good or otherwise would be
appreciated other than that
enjoy the podcast
okay margaret before we get into these
instagram questions i'm going to ask you
the two questions i ask every single
guest that is on the podcast
and the first is who alive or dead would
you most like to throw
cold spaghetti at who like
cold spaghetti um
well i think it would probably be donald
trump i mean
he should get some cold so he should
step in some cold spaghetti he should
get cold spaghetti threaded through
those toes
uh on a lighter note the other question
that i ask every single guest that's on
the podcast
is to tell us your worst pant [ __ ]
story or like a close
call situation but you can only use
three words
or three small phrases so mine for
example
is college jogging front lawn
okay mine is um
mini cooper okay
all fruit diet 101 free web
oh wow okay that was uh
yeah that paints a very vivid picture
yes
but no follow-up questions uh let's get
into these
instagram questions so we got a bunch of
really really good ones everyone is
absolutely adoring of you uh
someone wants to know well you kind of
touched on this a little bit but what's
become your favorite snack
during quarantine um
well actually i love um
guacamole but made in a mocha tate
which is a granite bowl with so it's
like a mortar and pestle but made of
granite
okay so it's um crushed instead of uh
with a fork you know so it's like as you
can do with a fork but if you crush it
with
stone then you're breaking apart the
the molecules so the cell walls are
they they uh taste different because
they're
crushed instead of i'm just broken so
when you
crush the cellulose it breaks apart
differently on your tongue
so all of the cell walls are um
it's it's like the the water molecules
are
it's i'm saying it wrong but the
cellulose is broken up differently so it
breaks up differently in your mouth
that's why it's it's great so i make it
with um
garlic and avocado and red onion which
is better raw
yeah and corn and bacon well and bacon
oh [ __ ] and bacon and fish sauce instead
of
salt really a little bit of um
red boat uh fish sauce which is very
it's it gives it a little bit of funk
but not too much so it's fishy
got it very very good that sounds
awesome i've never heard of that before
very cool wants to know if you could
hang out with one of your tattoos which
would it be
uh i would hang out with uh kuan yin
who is on the back she is the um
goddess of compassion oh and she is on
the
uh she she's the buddhist goddess of
compassion she's on the back of my
uh left calf cool
and she's um a work in progress
she's not finished but she's really
beautiful and she's always she's always
she's got my back she's on my left leg
so
that's awesome i love that uh someone
wants to know
genuine life advice or what you wish you
knew
20 years ago um
that it nothing's that bad nothing's
that big of a deal
it's not that big of a deal it's not
that big of a deal and also um
uh that i bought like i
worry so much about stuff yeah and um
uh the worst the the the worst thing
i've ever been through never happened
hmm
okay so it's like you always like put
yourself through so much [ __ ]
yeah it's just you doing it it's like i
always
worry so much and it's really just me ah
that's really helpful i think that yeah
we're so stuck in our heads that being
able to zoom out a little bit
and like see things as they are is it's
hard to do but very helpful
yeah emmy wants to know what do you
think the next steps are for asian
american representation
well i think it's really like that we're
just gonna see
and feel and hear uh more asian american
stories
and we need that we need to see and hear
and
feel and tell our stories and um see
them on the screen
see them on the television see that in
the books see them in the
you know movies just see them and and
hear them and podcasts and
everywhere we can see them and hear them
and tell them you know
they've got to come out and um that's
the next step is to
be there to witness them see them
tell them hear them all that um so
the audience be the teller be the
watcher be
the actor be all of that all of it
be the author very cool uh
kellen says i love her content i wish
you would start a vlog and do more music
video collabs please do you have any
plans for upcoming more like internet
centric
content or more music collabs i would
love to
i would love to i have been writing more
music and i have been
um doing other stuff i'm actually going
in to
start a movie in a couple of weeks
in new york and so i'm going into
quarantine for that
so hopefully maybe when i come out of
that i'll do more nice
uh and it's maybe nice to have a
specific reason to quarantine
yes it's bad knowing that there's a goal
a favorite comedy special at the moment
i am a comedy special i think um i
really
love well i always love uh
uh ali wong's um baby
i think that's like probably my favorite
very cool
that's so great i want to see one from
bobby lee to bobby lee's so funny
all the time yeah yeah yeah i really
love
i really love ali wong just everything
uh agree uh rebbe wants to know what's
something you wish more people
knew you for or as
um i guess
uh i don't know
i don't know i guess my activism because
i've always wanted to
work more as like um
an activist within the lgbtq
i plus community and also
working to combat
the experience of people experience
experiencing homelessness and help
people
um to get out of the experience of
homelessness and um yeah you know that
kind of stuff
you know i've worked around that a long
time so
um hoping that uh
receives more um traction but
you know it's also that thing of like
you don't want to like um
say hey i do this right right right it's
like
yeah you don't want to uh be
misinterpreted for
helping for the wrong reasons but you
also want to be helpful
i want to be helpful but only just
because i want more people to like
do it too yeah just so like i want more
people to be like hey
this is something that we should all do
um not so that
people are like oh look at how great she
is because she does that
more like i wish that more people would
be like hey i would like to get involved
it's more that
yeah and um so it's kind of one of those
things because there's a there's
through that whole thing of like that
culture of like virtue signaling which
is so weird
you know what's so weird is like when
people like pretend to rescue animals
wait this is a thing uh-oh yeah people
like
pretend to like rescue
animals but they're actually just
endangering
animals and then like pretending to
rescue them like
this weird [ __ ] it's like all on like
youtube and like
tick-tock of like they'll like coat
like ducks and like oil
and then like wash them and then it's
like wait
wait why do you have what
oh these are weird like shady
you can't trust anything now and it's
just like
what the [ __ ] are you doing
wow weird things that's uh yeah that's
very strange that is the side of uh
youtube and tic tac that i have not
ventured down yet it's cute
it's not cute um okay this is uh the
last question for you a real
real light question how to fix a life
that is falling apart
um well we're all falling apart and
we've all fallen apart at some extent
and sometimes
it's it's okay i've definitely fallen
apart
a bunch um i think that like i've
actually you know allowed myself to fall
apart
and i've had other people put me back
together it's not always the case
sometimes we have to fall apart in order
to be put back together
i think it's more like what is the
extent of falling apart and what is like
the point of
of uh falling apart for you and
some it's more like what do we need like
what is it
what is it that we need to not fall
apart or what
like usually when we fall apart is like
do we need to fall apart do we need that
to
see what what we need to be put back
together and
what's the worst thing that can happen
um
so it's kind of like what is falling
apart
mean and what does it look like and
what does it mean to lose everything and
what does it mean to
gain everything back and what is
everything so it's a very existential
kind of question yeah um
but it's really it is okay to fall apart
sometimes
and it's actually sometimes essential
yeah and i i
like a lot of times um i think
like kind of what you're saying that i
think people are are hesitant about it
because they think it's a bad
thing they think it's you know something
that shouldn't happen
but i feel like i relate most with the
people that are
that have gone through a falling apart
stage in their life
and if you think about people that have
never experienced that they seem like
serial killers in a way yeah they
only had a very like straight linear
path feels um
a little unrealistic in a sense
yeah so i mean it's kind of like if um
it's like what do you define as falling
apart like i have
been um you know taken out of my
uh home and put in an institution that's
pretty much falling apart like i was
like taken out
um in an intervention and given a choice
if you can either
um lose all of your friends
and family and continue your life as you
are or you can be put
in this institution and then i was
placed there for a year and a half
and that was really like my falling
apart yeah so
that's kind of you know that's thing
i've been fired i've been
um canceled cancelled i've been like
there's like
lots of things you know um so you know
when you reach those stages it's like is
that
falling apart i think so yeah and it's
like you you know you survive it
so it depends on like what is what is
sort of their definition so and you
you know you get stronger and you get
better and so i'm glad i experienced
that and i think that
you have to in order to grow up so i
think it's the the choice is
like let's not be afraid of it and let's
just go through it you have the only way
out is through
yeah yeah very very true i love that uh
and i think like you said earlier a
little bit the
what is the worst possible thing and
like really trying to
kind of get yourself to really think
about
what's the worst possible thing what's
the worst possible thing and a lot of
times it's like what you're
saying to yourself rather than the
reality of the situation
um and being able to figure out like you
said why are you falling apart like what
is there to gain after you fall apart
like what is the reason for this
i think is really important that's very
helpful margaret thank you so much
thank you before we wrap up completely
usually
hey little girl yeah uh usually we
uh give a personalized fortune cookie
from us to our guests when we're doing
this in person
but because we're doing this virtually
we have a virtual fortune cookie
for you that i believe melissa has
emailed to you oh yes
the new bay bridge linking east bay to
sf
took like 11 years to make and over 6
billion
including the increased total ferrous
but guess what it's going to rust soon
and need to be rebuilt
this type of situation may be applicable
to many
parts of life for an american in 2020 so
that's nice
that's a a bit of a journey to get there
but we got there
it's true that bridge was so annoying
too because it took forever
i mean it was so and
i couldn't believe how much it
really affected um the commutes and
it was crazy it was crazy but yeah
that's how it goes it's 20 20. uh
margaret where can people find you and
everything that you
are up to if they don't already know
people can find me um
at margaret cho on twitter at
margaret underscore show on the
instagram they can find me
um uh margaret show.com online
and um yeah i'll be back on tour when
this whole thing is over
check in um yeah so your podcast going
on that people can listen to
it's called the uh the margaret show
it's on anywhere you can listen to
podcasts
awesome well thank you so much guys go
check out everything that she's up to
also the dog content is a hundred
percent so
you won't be upset and we'll see you
guys next time on another episode of not
too deep goodbye
too deep too deep too deep deep not too
deep
disgrace not too deep is a production of
grace helbig incorporated producer
melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis post
production sound by chris henry
and an extra special thanks to flula for
the theme music